to return to sustainable levels over
time and we an immigration policy is
under constant review Sarah Atherton
thank you the labor applied Coalition in
Cardiff has declared Wales a sanctuary
for all the world is welcome however
their Ukrainian super sponsor scheme
fell apart due to lack of accommodation
and planning with families still crammed
into one single room so what discussions
has the minister had with the Welsh
labor government about the collapse of
their super sponsor scheme and just a
minute to know how many families are
still inappropriately placed Home
Secretary
well we are very proud of our track
record in this country of providing
Sanctuary to people in need and I'm very
proud of the support that the government
has given to ukrainians fleeing Putin's
barbaric War but when it comes to
broader accommodation costs relating to
Asylum Seekers it's clear we're spending
far too much every day six million
pounds a day three billion pounds a year
on Asylum seekers in hotels but the
honor my honorable friend raises a very
important Point she speaks frankly to
Labor's abject failure to offer any
viable plan when it comes to support
they're naive about the problem and
they're unrealistic about the solution
labor has absolutely no idea no plan and
they're letting whales down James Durley
thank you very much Mr Speaker does the
government have any plans to amend the
minimum salary requirement for the
skilled worker visa scheme
um
Mr Speaker we always keep the salary
threshold under review but as I said net
migration is too high and we need to get
overall numbers down how do we do that
well employers need to recruit more
people already here rather than
advertise abroad so much we also need to
get more people off welfare and back
into economic activity in our welfare
reforms will help that objective and we
cannot ignore the pressures that record
levels of people coming to the UK put on
housing Supply public services and on
community relations that's why we need
to focus on lowering net migration Tim
farrin thank you Mr Speaker of course in
some parts the UK net emigration is the
problem and I wonder if the Home
Secretary would pay attention to the
plight of our economy in the lakes and
The Dales when almost two-thirds of
businesses are failing to be able to
meet their capacity of the demand that's
out there because of a lack of a
Workforce I've been speaking to her
right honorable friend about a youth
Mobility Visa scheme negotiated
bilaterally with other countries in
Europe to solve our economic needs here
so our hospitality and tourism industry
can survive will she tell me how she's
getting on with those discussions
I'm secretary well migration is a very
complex issue and of course we have to
balance the needs of the labor market uh
and that's why we're very pleased to
support uh particularly and well-crafted
youth Mobility schemes one with India
I've just come back from New Zealand
where we've expanded the youth Mobility
scheme there they're great schemes
whereby there can be the exchange of
young people and they can come here to
serve and work in our economy Jim shupp
thank you Mr Speaker I thank the
Secretary of State very much for for the
response
um it's very clear that the issue of
migration must be settled and sorted out
at the same time and my concept is
Frankfurt it's very important to have
those who have come from Eastern Europe
those who have come from the Middle East
those who have come from from Africa as
well who contribute to the economy so
when it comes to net migration I think
the secret is very committed to ensuring
that that continues but what discussions
has these secular state had with the the
Northern Ireland assembly in relation to
the smart ensure that we can continue to
have the workers that we need thank you
Home Secretary well there's no single
measure which can be used to control net
migration but as the Prime Minister has
been clear that migration is too high
that's why I announced a series of
measures uh recently aimed at the number
of students which is exponentially rised
risen in the last few years focusing on
the number of student dependents and
ensuring that students come here in a
much more proportionate and balanced way
now come to shutter Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker will the Home
Secretary wish the deputy chairman of
the conservative party a speedy recovery
from the terrible sick bug which I
understand has prevented him from
launching this morning an entirely
different conservative immigration
policy to the policy of the conservative
Home Secretary and does she agree with
him that social care visas should be
canceled yes or no
well Mr Speaker the so sorry fact of the
matter here is that labor want open
borders and unlimited migration and
there's a real malaise descending upon
the labor pod they don't even know what
they think to be honest labor City Khan
has said he wants more migration Labor's
party chairman has confirmed that
numbers could rise under a labor
government and the shadow Home Secretary
when she was asked about whether she
wanted net migration to rise or for in
characteristic style that we've come to
know and love couldn't even answer the
question Mr Speaker that's what you
always get with labor
can I just say you have no
responsibility for the labor party I
think in furnace it is almost this
question a vet Cooper
well the hunter didn't couldn't answer
the question does she support her own
social care visas or not
spent all weekend briefing that she
agrees with her back benches but today
she can't even answer the basic question
making up stuff about the labor policy a
labor party won't help her when her
party has been in power for 13 years and
where work visas have doubled exactly
because they have failed to tackle skill
shortages or tackle issues in the labor
market this is total chaos we've got a
Rwanda policy that isn't removing anyone
an impact assessment which says her
policies won't work and will cost much
more a 50 drop in removals of foreign
criminals because the inspector says the
home office can't even identify who can
be removed record number of people in
hotels record high Asylum backlog and
back Ventures writing her immigration
policy because they don't think she's up
to the job it's been a humiliating week
few weeks for the homes or order
oh
sorry I'm not going to take advantage of
me in that way that is totally unfair I
can't pull one side up for them to take
advantage of it I expect all the back
benches to be able to get their
questions in today it is about everybody
in the same involvement so please don't
do that okay I'm secretary thank you Mrs
keeper Mr Speaker we we all know that
it's only this side of the house it's
only the conservative party it's only
this prime minister that has a serious
plan to stop the boats and stop illegal
migration and that labor only stands for
one thing open borders unlimited
migration they'd rather spend their time
campaigning to block the deportation of
foreign criminals than back our illegal
migration Bill they're on the side of
the criminal gangs not on the side of
the British people bloody Callum
question number two Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker if you remember
we'll recall that we met the two of us
just a few weeks ago on May the 17th
together with industry representatives
to discuss the issue of hemp licensing
and I thank him for taking the time and
trouble uh to organize that meeting uh
there is as he knows a light touch
process for licensing industrial hemp
and in fact since 2013 the number of
hemp licenses has increased from six up
to 134.
recollect the conversation well but we
have an opportunity within the UK to
grow hemp on an industrial scale and
from that feed many growing industries
that use hemp to produce environmentally
friendly products the growth of these
industries has been hampered by overly
complicated regulations and a poor
application process meanwhile foreign
companies are racing ahead in this Arena
to protect UK farmers and encourage UK
industry with the minister considering
giving the licensing process over to
defra and make the process farmer
friendly
what is of course important to make sure
that uh UK industry can compete globally
in a light touch regulatory framework is
important to that we should of course be
conscious that some parts of the plant
uh contain high levels of THC and do
need regulation which is the uh home
office's concern but I can tell in my
meeting uh deafra colleagues in the very
near future to make sure that our
approach to regulation is as light touch
as possible because like him I do want
to see our domestic industry flourish
and like him I don't want to see any
excessive regulation Andrew
number three Mr Speaker minister
thank you Mr Speaker the government has
said it will be reviewing the funding
formula and I hope to have news for the
house in the relatively near future
about initiating uh the consultation
process it is the case that the funding
formula the police funding formula is
quite out of date and it does need
overhauling and that is something we're
working on the record
1455 number of police officers in
bedfordshire in the recent six million
pound special Grant are both very
welcome indeed but does see police
Minister recognize that it's simply not
fair right to go on funding a force with
a series of one-off special grants which
really do need to be part of core
funding
friend makes a good point and I should
take this opportunity uh to pay tribute
to the bedfordshire police and crime
commissioner Festus akinbusoye who has
done who has done a fantastic job for
the people of bedfordshire advocating
for more funding via the special Grant
and he was successful in doing that he
is a great representative for the people
of bedfordshire and I'm pleased that he
has delivered record police numbers in
bedfordshire just as the government have
delivered record ever numbers of police
across the whole of England and Wales
thank you very much Mr Speaker Chief
Constable of West Yorkshire police John
Robbins qpm recently told the BBC that
his boss does not have the resources it
needs to deliver the service the public
expects cutting through the spin he said
the force had been down 2 000 staff and
140 million pounds since 2010. he said
it could deal with major incidents and
crimes but only at a cost to
neighborhood police him this is from a
force that was rated outstanding in
planning the use of resources in its
latest hmic FRS inspection so which bit
of policing does the minister think
should not be done because forces simply
haven't got the resources Minister will
the shadow Minister will of course know
that in the police funding settlement
for this year 23-24 uh there is an extra
around about 500 million pounds in fact
slightly over 500 million pounds for
police forces up and down the country
which has enabled us to deliver a record
ever number of officers 140 39
572 officers around about three and a
half thousand more than under the last
Labor government in uh in West Yorkshire
which asked about neighborhood crime is
down by 30 since 2019 and overall crime
excluding fraud and computer misuse
which only came into the figures
recently since 2010 is down by 52
percent and I'm still waiting for the
shadow Home Secretary to apologize for
being a member of a government that
presided over crime levels double those
we have today
tomorrow
number four Mr Speaker Minister Mr
Speaker with your permission I'll group
this question with question 21 we're
making good progress and the latest home
of Statistics show Asylum decisions are
up with a 35 increase in Asylum
decisions from last year productivity
has increased and we're on track to have
2 500 decision makers by September which
represents a quadrupling of the number
of caseworkers
like many members across the house I'm
constantly being contacted by refugees
desperate to know what is happening to
their Asylum after years of waiting so I
asked the home office how many refugees
in Newcastle had been waiting one two
three four five years and the answer
came back
they don't know they don't even record
the data so instead of indulging in
unworkable unethical illegal and
unaffordable flights of random fantasy
why doesn't the Home Secretary focus on
her day job and fix the Asylum backlog
well as I've just said we are making
good progress on reducing the current
Asylum backlog but important though the
backlog is it can't be the totality of a
plan and this is the point that the
party opposite don't seem to understand
you have to stop the boats coming in the
first place that is the only sustainable
way to tackle the issue and even if you
grant your way out of this problem it
seems to be what the shadow Home
Secretary proposes the pressures to the
state still remain they're simply
transferred to local authorities and the
benefit system and the British taxpayer
continues to pick up the bill
well that's an interesting definition of
being on track because haven't the
number of decision makers actually
fallen from January to may this year
from uh
1333 to
1280. I had a letter recently from a
pass on to me of a constitution for a
local solicitor saying all possible
averages have been considered to avoid
this situation but regrettably the home
office is long-term failure to progress
Asylum claims and current government
immigration policy has made it
financially unsustainable for this
solicitors to continue legally aided
work how does it help us as MPS on both
sides of the house in our constituency
offices and the backlog that the home
office says it wants to reduce by making
sure people don't have the legal
representation they actually need to
unblock the system and allow progress in
these cases Minister well I can assure
the honor of gentleman that the problem
with our Asylum system is not the lack
of lawyers there's plenty of legal
Representatives around we've had strong
overall progress on the backlog and I'm
pleased to say that the early data that
I've received suggested last week saw
the best performance in four years
thank you Mr Speaker I know how
seriously the minister takes dealing
with the Legacy backlog but as the Home
Secretary showed at the recent home
first Select Committee in order to deal
with that backlog in the time frame the
governor set itself it would require at
least a quadrupling of the number of
cases being dealt with as from the 1st
of June and even with the extra 500 at
Stoke just appointed that it's going to
be challenging so will the minister give
me assurance that if we've not actually
managed to clear the background before
the end of the year that will not be
done by a blanket amnesty
for this stuff well my honorable friend
makes an important point and the Home
Secretary the Prime Minister and I
explicitly chose not to pursue the
blanket amnesty approach that the last
Labor government pursued instead we put
the hard yards in to improve
productivity by streamlining processes
reducing our necessary bureaucracy
ensuring that we're appropriate
interviews were conducted in a timely
fashion and recruiting more decision
makers since my rightful friend the Home
Secretary appeared before the committee
I'm pleased to say that the data coming
out of our caseworking team is very
strong we are seeing significant
progress as I just said the last week
the early indication suggests was the
best for over four years
I'm a bit mystify given that 895 of
these applications are successful surely
if you speed up the process and make it
easier and easier just more and more
people will come isn't the only solution
actually to detain people and to support
them offshore them and those that
suggest anything else are living in
Cloud Cuckoo Land and every single
county is going to face what we face in
Lincolnshire with thousands of illegal
migrants have to have been housed in
unsuitable places let's have an answer
for once
well the approach to the home section
I've taken has been both to ensure that
where there are high Grant rate
nationalities cases are pursued swiftly
but also where there are very low Grant
rates like albanians where these are
individuals from a safe European country
and can and should be returned as
quickly as possible that we do just that
and at this point in the year last year
30 of those arriving from uh on small
boats were coming from Albania today
it's less than two percent so that
Arrangement is making good progress but
my rightful friend does make an
important point which is that those who
suggest you can simply Grant your way
out of this problem I'm afraid are
hopelessly naive the idea that the
individuals coming across on small boats
are in the most cases going to make a
significant net contribution to our
economy are wrong the cost to the
taxpayer are very significant the
ongoing support in terms of Education
access to welfare and Community cohesion
are very significant and that's why we
need to stop the boats in the first
place shall The Minister's a student can
I thank you very much Mr Speaker the
government's destruction of its own
Asylum system can best be described as
an act of arson and its plans to fix it
are utterly farcical they've sent more
home secretaries than Asylum Seekers to
Rwanda they sent the they sent the Prime
Minister on a Victory lap in Dover
apparently failing to notice that the
weather improves over the summer and the
boat numbers increase and they were in
such a flap about losing votes on their
bigger backlog bill that they resorted
to dragging Lord labedev of Siberia into
the division lobbies now the court of
appeal ruling has revealed that Rwanda
is only able to process 100 claims per
year around 0.3 percent of those who
arrived on small boats last year so can
the minister tell me what he's planning
to do with the remaining 99.7 and does
he therefore agree with me that the
prospect of the Rwanda plan actually
deterring any migrant from crossing the
channel is close to zero
well I used to say that the labor party
don't have a plan but the truth is they
do have a plan it's a plan that would
make things significantly worse it's a
plan that will ensure more granting of
cases more safe and legal routes so even
more individuals come here more hotels
more cost to the British taxpayer and
what what I think is so disgraceful is
the level of hypocrisy and to you only
have to look at the record of Labor
Wales to see that in Wales the Welsh
Minister for social justice declared
labor run Wells a nation of sanctuary or
in the Senate on 15 occasions but across
the same period labor-run Wales
accommodated 176 fewer Asylum seekers in
fact the latest published data shows
that labor-run Wales are taking just
half the number of people that they
should be per capita for Stevens thank
you Mr Speaker number five
thank you Mr Speaker
uh I have regularly engaged with the
devolved administrations on the illegal
migration Bill since its introduction in
March in addition to my periodic
meetings with my ministerial
counterparts on a variety of immigration
issues most recently I met with the
Scottish Minister for equalities
migration and refugees in May looking
ahead the bill is on the agenda for the
inter-ministerial group for safety
security and migration which my writing
friend the Home Secretary will chair
later this month interesting thank the
minister for that answer but this bill
will place restrictions on the powers of
Scottish ministers moving the
entitlement for victims of human
trafficking and exploitation to access
Scottish government-funded Support
Services I will undermine the Scottish
government's ability to deliver on its
own trafficking and exploitation
strategy now we know the roots that the
government's damaging ideology is
dragging this government down but why
should Scotland's elected Parliament and
those have devolved administrations they
dragged down the same routes when it's
abundantly clear we want no part of our
hostile environmental ideology finished
Mr Speaker if the Scottish government
cared so deeply about this issue they
would accommodate more Asylum Seekers
the SM kidney government is
accommodating just four and a half
percent of the total Asylum population
being accommodated in the UK when
Scotland makes up 8.1 percent and I took
the time to look at some of the
statistics for those local authorities
in Scotland where the SMP are the
largest party clack manager zero Asylum
Seekers Dundee zero Asylum Seekers East
air share zero Eastern bartender zero
Midlothian zero North Ayrshire want to
take a guess Mr Speaker zero North
atlanticshire six no you were ah no no
no no no you're gonna get my drift we
can't read out full numbers this is not
the Yellow Pages adverts so please one
statistic Tuesday when I get to five I
really have gotta worry no then let's
have the SMP Sports and Patrick ready
speaker clearly thinks that this is a
very clever line but he knows well that
Glasgow takes more refugees per head of
population than any other local
Authority in the whole of the United
Kingdom and this line that he's trotting
out is simply wrong and it's insulting
to everyone in Scotland who's opened
their homes to ukrainians the
communities across the country who've
welcomed syrians and the volunteers in
the big city who work with Asylum
Seekers every day helping them to
overcome trauma if you want Scotland to
do more to welcome refugees when is it
going to devolve the power and the
financial levers that would allow us to
do so yeah yeah at least Mr Speaker for
good reason immigration is a reserve
matter but the statistics that I just
read out make the point as clearly as
can be they try their very best to
undermine the government to work to stop
the boats but they refused to
accommodate these people when they
arrive and the costs of their fake
humanitarianism are borne by everyone
but themselves it's not just hypocrisy
it's deeply irresponsible and the public
have had enough
it's not the Scottish government's
policy
integration refugees and Asylum Seekers
that have been ruled unlawful by the
court of appeal if he wants the system
to work and he wants the Scottish
government to do its part then what he
needs to do is more action to clear the
backlog as we've heard there needs to be
proper safe and legal routes for people
to arrive and then give them the right
to work when they get here because then
they can pay for their own accommodation
and they don't want they won't cost the
taxpayers money yeah Mr Speaker just the
other day the home office suggested to
the Scottish government that a vessel
that had been used to house Ukrainian
refugees in Leith could be used for
others who are Asylum Seekers the same
vessel the same poor the same provider
the same package
what did the SMP say
no
I don't care question number six please
Mr Speaker I'm secretary thank you Mr
Speaker well I'm pleased that the court
of appeal found that the government is
not in breach of our obligations under
the refugee convention I fundamentally
disagree with the Judgment that Rwanda
is not a safe place for refugees and we
are seeking permission to appeal
the government takes its International
obligations very seriously and we are
satisfied that satisfied the provisions
in the illegal migration Bill comply
with the refugee convention
but the fundamental principle remains
those are needs of protection should
claim Asylum at the earliest opportunity
and then the first safe country that
they reach
thank you Mr Speaker and the Home
Secretary and the government's own
website and say that they're they're
satisfied that the provisions in the
illegal migration Bill comply with the
1951 Union Refugee convention but I'm
looking for it so Clarity from the Home
Secretary what exactly is it about
persecuting the most vulnerable groups
creating a hostile environment and
stripping people of the right to seek
safety that complies so well with the
U.N refugee
Obsession well as I've made clear we
take our International obligations very
seriously and we are satisfied that the
bill complies with the refugee
commission but Mr Speaker with respect
to the honorable lady I'm not going to
take lectures from the SMP on this
matter they are as my right or my friend
said they're the phony humanitarians in
this debate who are happy to support
Asylum Seekers as long as they're
nowhere near Scotland and when they stop
opposing the vessel in Leith which will
attack which will house more Asylum
Seekers then we can have a serious
conversation fill the polar bear and
Refugee agency itself has its own Asylum
Seeker relocation program it flies
Asylum Seekers from Libya to Rwanda on a
scheme part funded by the European Union
so how on Earth can Rwanda be deemed not
to be a safe country if the U.N Refugee
agency itself is using it as a safe
haven
as always my honorable friend makes a
very powerful poem and I couldn't agree
more with what he said the unhcr runs a
very extensive scheme in Rwanda and
supports the resettlement of many
thousands of migrants I've met some of
them in my recent visit to Rwanda they
are happy and they are grateful for the
generosity and welcome that Rwanda has
offered them and allowed them to restart
their lives and I'm frankly very
disappointed very disappointed by the
constant smears and assumptions which
have frankly based on outdated and
ignorant views denigrating our allies in
Rwanda I am nothing but grateful to our
partners in Rwanda for their continued
cooperation Gordon Henderson question
number seven Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker well I'm pleased to
report that since 2010 according to the
crime survey violence is down by 41 and
criminal damage is down by 68 but we'd
like to do more that's why we have now
record ever numbers of police why we're
investing in the safer streets fund uh
200 million for the Youth endowment fund
and 170 million pounds for the violence
reduction unit we're also uh launching
we have already launched our anti-social
Behavior strategy that the Home
Secretary will speak about in a moment
but now is a good time I think to put on
record an intervention made by Mr
Speaker in his capacity as Member of
Parliament for Chorley thanks to his
recent intervention uh with me and with
the chief Constable uh truly Town Center
is one of those areas that will receive
antisocial Behavior Uh hotspot patrols
and I'm sure the people are surely are
very grateful uh to Mr Speaker for the
intervention he made on their behalf
well done Mr Speaker
um I'd like to thank the minister for
his reply but to some young people who
are arrested because they've been guilty
of anti-social Behavior or so-called
low-level crime are released without
charge because there is a reluctance to
criminalize them too often these
youngsters go on to commit further
multiple crimes under arrested and
released without charge each time what
steps will my right honorable friend
take to end this roundabout of
unpunished crime and ensure that young
people who repeatedly break the law are
not released without charge but are
treated as what they are which is
criminals yeah look at this stuff but we
do want to see tougher action on things
like antisocial behavior and on public
drug use we should have no tolerance
zero tolerance for any of those things
one of the things we are now launching
as part of the ASB strategy is instant
Justice where people who perpetrate acts
of antisocial Behavior will very rapidly
ideally within 48 Hours be made to do uh
Cleanup in their local area those kind
of things to pay back visibly publicly
rapidly and uh you know with enforcement
we're trialing that in 10 police force
areas starting this month July and it'll
be rolled out to every single police
force in the country with funding by
April of next year so I completely agree
with everything honorable friend said
it's a beautiful thank you Mr Speaker
the minister may not be aware that Irish
chair of the cross-party youth Finance
commission we published an interim
report in 2018 and a final one in 2020
and our first recommendation was that
the government adopt a public health
approach to tackling violence through
Regional violence reduction units and
long-term strategies so what action is
the minister taking to ensure that
Finance reduction units have the
long-term funding they need to achieve
the best possible outcomes
I do agree with the approach The
Honorable lady and just set out and we
have already taken action she asked
about long-term plans she'll be aware
the youth endowment fund which has 200
million pounds is a 10-year program and
she'll be aware that violence reduction
units in some places called violence
reduction Partnerships have so far
received 170 million pounds and they
receive funding each and every year
including an allocation uh this year and
the kind of things that we find work
include diversionary activities for
young people and in fact the chief
executive of the yet told me when I
asked him uh what the most effective
intervention is he said it was cognitive
behavioral therapy which gets used as
well but I would just repeat Mr Speaker
just one statistic which I mentioned
earlier since 2010 violence is down by
41 criminal damage down by 68 percent
thank you Mr Speaker a report today
found that nearly half of women who
experienced or witnessed a crime in the
past year chose not to report it because
they don't believe that the police would
treat it seriously his Majesty's
inspector in his latest state of the
nation report said the police are
experiencing one of their biggest crises
in living memory they're a widespread
systematic failings and they simply
aren't getting the basics right so my
question to the minister is having
pushed our British model of policing by
consent to the very Brink does the
government take responsibility do they
agree with the inspector that
substantial reform is essential will
they back Labor's plans to restore
neighborhood policing half serious
violence and raise confidence in every
force or is he happy to keep twiddling
his thumbs while the criminals get away
with it
said I in the gentist terms my
constituency neighbor has a bit of a
cheek talking about reducing crime when
crime levels according to the crime
survey were around about double under
the last Labor government than they are
today I mean she shakes her head but
it's the office for National statistics
and it is the only uh statistically
recognized long-term measure of crime
according to the ons so she doesn't like
the ons figures she can go and argue
with them she may not like them but
those are the figures in relation to her
uh quite serious question about about
rasso and other serious assaults
particularly on women and the proportion
being reported is much higher now than
it has been a few years ago and that is
to be welcomed there is a lot more to do
which is why there is a rape review and
a rape action plan and my runnable
friend the Home Secretary I'm honorable
friend the safeguarding minister are
working hard on that operation sateria
Bluestone it's fully rolled out by uh
just about the end of June just a few uh
days ago and we are seeing significant
increases in the number of relevant
charges but they are still too low they
do need to go uh higher and that is why
we're investing in more rasso specialist
officers that work is continuing
the question number nine Mr
speaker's top shelf vote yourself it
doesn't need to sound so uncertain uh Mr
Speaker with your permission I'd like to
group this with number 14.
earlier uh in the year Mr Speaker I
launched the antisocial Behavior action
plan increasing funding for police and
crime Commissioners by over 100 million
pounds delivering stronger and swifter
punishment increasing police visibility
and response and banning nitrous oxide
and social behavior is not a low-level
crime it blights communities and that's
why this government is committed to
tackling it effectively my case Brett
thank you Mr Speaker
um today to coincide with anti-social
Behavior Awareness Week the all
parliamentary group with resolved the
ASB at charity of published a report
with amongst other things demonstrates
that 1.7 million people per day
experiencing anti-social Behavior 58
believe the government is not doing
enough would the Home Secretary meet
with me and members of the all
parliamentary group to look at the
recommendations in that report
um well I really thank the honorable
gentleman for his work on the all-party
Parliamentary group and I'm sure
policing Minister and or myself will
meet with him to learn more about the
vital work that he's been leading but
let me just take this opportunity to
applaud the officers in his area in
Cheshire uh police force I've had the
pleasure of meeting the excellent Chief
Council Mark Roberts I applaud the
conservative police and crime
commissioner John Dwyer who's rolled out
a scheme on antisocial Behavior rolling
out more CCTV and increasing the
response the First Response the first
responder response there's a record
number of police officers in Cheshire
they've received over 3 million pounds
worth of safer streets funding and what
are the results a 26 fall in
neighborhood crime and a 17 fall in
drugs offenses in Cheshire that's common
sense policing thanks to the police
officers and government support Steve
Morgan thank you Mr Speaker Hampton Isle
of Wight police is one of the lowest
funded forces in the UK and with a
decade cuts to Youth Services
anti-social Behavior has been left to
thrive under this government we've seen
the consequences of this at South parade
Pier at the camber and at many other
places in Portsmouth neighborhood
policing is vital to crack down on ASB
which ruins so many lives therefore what
explanation can the Home Secretary
provide for halving the number of pcsos
over the last 13 years
of secretary well The Honorable
gentleman and I are represent
constituencies which are served by the
same police force and I am really proud
actually of the track record in
Hampshire I'm really proud of how the
new Chief constables Scott Chilton has
assumed his role with real focus on Back
to Basics policing I'm really proud of
how the conservative police and crime
commissioner Donna Jones has led
initiatives so that every community in
Hampshire will have a name will have
named dedicated police officers and
pcsos serving them really bolstering
neighborhood policing and building
confidence and I'm really proud of the
fact that Hampshire has seen a 15 fall
in neighborhood crime since 2019 Common
Sense policing serving the community
thank you Mr Speaker does my right
honorable friend agree with me that some
of the principal victims of anti-social
Behavior are young people and so it's
absolutely right what the government is
doing bringing forward new measures to
tackle anti-social Behavior to make
safer our street South Parks our public
spaces for the vast majority of young
people who don't engage in those
negative behaviors
um
my Rhino friend is absolutely
correct in what he says there's such a
need for a greater diversion and greater
support for young people so that they
don't spend their time loitering in
shopping centers or causing a nuisance
in car parts or harassing members of the
community that's why our anti-social
Behavior action plan commits uh
considerable funding it's over 160
million pounds worth of new funding
including funding for an increased
police present in presence in a ASB Hot
Spot areas and funding to support the
rollout of diversionary resources to
support young people so that they don't
fall into crime they don't fall into
antisocial Behavior the oceans are
exceptional my specialist Charlie
Inspire one Robbie Moore you Mr Speaker
yet again in ilkley and in Mali in my
constituency Travelers have set up camp
cause damage intimidated residents which
just last weekend resulted in ilkley
pool having to temporarily close and
when they have gone they leave a
complete mess which all then has to be
cleaned up and taxpayers expense so will
the Home Secretary meet with me to
discuss what additional support West
Yorkshire police and our local Council
can get to address this ongoing issue
Home Secretary well my honorable friend
raises a really important point about
illegal encampments and travelers who
like communities by causing a nuisance
and threatening uh in some cases
communities it's unacceptable Behavior
that's why we legislated in the police
crime sentencing act to toughen up the
powers and the measures available to the
police so they can take uh more robust
steps in relation to this issue but yeah
I'm very happy to speak to him about
what more can be done locally Paula
Templeton question number 10 Mr Speaker
Minister Mr Speaker with the operation
I'll group this question with number 15
the home office seeks to end the use of
hotels and move Asylum Seekers to less
expensive and more suitable
accommodation to support this we're
bringing in to use large disused
military sites and vessels which will
provide adequate safe secure
non-detained accommodation for Asylum
Seekers which also reduce the pull
factor to the United Kingdom well that's
Hamilton
thank you Mr Speaker I recently received
an email from the home office which said
that the use of hotels two out two hours
Asylum Seekers is inappropriate and that
Reliance on them must be reduced in the
same email the old Muppets informed me
that they plan to increase the use of
Hotel accommodation for Asylum seekers
in my constituency of erdington by a
hundred and fifty nine percent this
represents the single biggest increase
in the whole of Birmingham so can the
minister tell me how on Earth she can ex
oh sorry how on Earth he can expect the
country to trust them when he can't even
keep his policies consist consistent in
the same email
well the policy that we've adopted is
one of maximizing the capacity of the
hotels that we have for as long as we
have them that's saving the taxpayer at
least quarter of a billion pounds and
it's reducing the Reliance upon hotels
elsewhere in the country I do appreciate
that there are pressures on her local
Authority and I also appreciate that
there are some labor local authorities
like Westminster city council that say
that Asylum Seekers must be housed in
individual ensuite bedrooms we don't
agree with that that's a gross waste of
taxpayers money and would make the UK a
soft touch Jeff Smith well Mr Speaker in
my consistency I've had the same
experience as my colleague murdington
but the question I wanted to ask was
about unaccompanied Asylum seeking
children the home office still hasn't
explained how they're going to find
these children are missing from a sale
and accommodation so will they set out
what the plans are to do this and find
these vulnerable people yeah Minister
well we've been very clear that we and
the police take any young person who
goes missing from a hotel or any other
form of accommodation extremely
seriously local police forces and home
office Personnel treat that exactly as
they would do any other child going
missing and conduct the full missing
person's inquiry but the only
sustainable answer to young people
living in hotels is to stop the boats in
the first place doing nothing is not an
option doing nothing will lead to more
young people living in those hotels
being exposed to human traffickers James
Gray what I do very much welcome to
Minister's determination to move away
from hotels and towards other
accommodation will it give particular
attention to the wheelchair hotel or
Golf Club in my own constituency which
has gone up in numbers no 120 people
there they're all crammed into a very
small combination there's nothing bad
from the point of view of the golf club
members and from the point of view of
the neighboring long-term residence
president next door but it's also
extremely bad place the point of view of
the Asylum Seekers they have nowhere to
go they have nothing to do they have an
education facility they've got no
religions they are stuck there in the
middle of the countryside with no
transport it's quite the wrong place for
them to be well the minister please give
particular attention to the Wilshire
Hotel sir well I'm familiar with the
hotel in his Constitution and the
concerns that he's raised I will take a
look at that but as I said previously
the answer to this challenge is to stop
the boats coming in the first place and
that is why we all need to support the
illegal migration Bill if you want more
hotels you would oppose it the labor
party's policy will see more hotels the
shadow Home Secretary will end up with
more hotels to her name than Paris
Hilton
thank you I don't know how to follow
that Mr Speaker
um uh
all members would like to see a
reduction in the number of hotels used
for sun accommodation I'm sure that's
true but will the ministers just spend a
moment to congratulate the community of
schoenbrook and in particular Reverend
Paulo de Leo and Council Doug McMurdo
and actually providing a welcoming
environment for people who are put in
such accommodation I think there are
signs across the country where
communities do come together in these
difficult circumstances to achieve an
outcome that's beneficial for everyone
well I'd be very happy to put on my
record the good work being done by his
constituents he's right to say that
there are voluntary and Community groups
Charities and churches right across the
country who are supporting Asylum
Seekers whilst they're in this form of
accommodation and we and our providers
facilitate that wherever possible
uh question number one Mr Speaker I'm
secretary
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'm gonna make a short
topical statement the information that
meta and other tech companies give to UK
law enforcement helps to protect around
1200 children and leads to over a
hundred arrests of suspected child
abusers every month but meta plans to
roll out end-to-end encryption soon
without safeguards they will no longer
proactively detect and alert authorities
to child grooming and abuse material on
Facebook messenger and Instagram Direct
this will be a huge Boon to anyone who
wants to hurt a child the Online safety
bill will hold Tech firms to account but
indifference to abuse is intolerable
I've written to Mark Zuckerberg along
with my right honorable friend the
security minister Children's Charities
campaign groups to out loud outline our
profound concerns and last week I was in
New Zealand at the five eyes security
conference where there was widespread
support for working together to ensure
social media companies put child safety
first they're the tallest thank you Mr
Speaker following recent night crime in
see my constituency and within the
Medway towns will my right honorable
friend meet with me in our Kent Police
crime commissioner Matthew Scott to
discuss funding and how the home office
can further support Kent Police with the
increased challenges that we are facing
in Kent due to our proximity to London
acceptance
well I very much appreciate the
particular challenges in Kent
um relating to knife crime and uh that's
why I'm very glad that since 2019 Kent
has received 5.5 million pounds in core
violence reduction unit grant funding
and 730 000 pounds in additional support
for targeted youth interventions I have
met with the police and crime
commissioner I have also met with the
chief Constable Tim Scott they are both
excellent at leading their forces there
is now a record number of police
officers in Kent and very I'm sure the
policy Minister will meet my honorable
my own referenter discusses this
particular issue but there's a lot of
progress but we can do better
thank you Mr Speaker the Home Secretary
will be aware of the documentary last
week on the relationship between Boris
Johnson and others and former KGB
officer Alexander levadef about their
meeting in Italian Villa ignoring of
security advice and Lord's appointments
and the decision not to sanction
Alexander lebedev given the importance
of National Security will she tell the
house whether she has any concerns about
these reports and will she set up an
independent investigation into what
happened into who knew what and into how
far the security risk spreads
well at the home office pretty Minister
and myself take very seriously the
threats posed by hostile State actors
that's why my writer Mall friends
security minister is chairing a
defending democracy task force bringing
together agencies government departments
and a cross-white hall approach to
tackling the very serious threats that
we all face as parliamentarians as those
in public office and I gently remind her
that one of her own parliamentary
colleagues has been has a very dubious
track record when it comes to working
with the Chinese Communist Party
Celine Saxby thank you Mr Speaker what
steps is my right honorable friend
taking to ensure that police funding
reflects rurality and the huge uplift in
population experienced in remote Coastal
locations during the summer tourist
season
in response to an earlier question it is
the government's intention
um to consult in the into course on a
new police funding formula and part of
that consultation we're involve looking
at the factors that should be taken into
account those might include things like
population and crime levels but things
like morality sparsity and seasonality
particularly seasonal tourism are likely
to form part of the new formula and I
would encourage members on both sides to
engage closely with the consultation
when it comes forward to make sure those
factors are properly accounted for
uh thank you Mr Speaker and our firm
members to marriage sort of interests in
recent weeks the media have carried
stories of patients who were receiving
medical cannabis on private
prescriptions that are now having their
prescriptions paid for by the NHS on the
surface this is a Great Leap Forward but
parents of children with intractable
epilepsy who've been asking for studies
for years are still being ignored with
the home office consider reopening the
2018 licensing scheme to enable the
children already being privately
prescribed to have access via their NHS
GP
Minister and well I think um many of the
uh cannabis based compounds uh were a
few years ago wholesale moved to
schedule two enabling them to be
prescribed the question about NHS
prescription that you ask is a perfectly
reasonable perfectly fair question and
but of course prescriptions on the NHS
are a matter for dhsc and for the NHS
including I suppose the NHS in Scotland
I'd be very happy to pass on his inquiry
to them on Henderson
thank you Mr Speaker can I assure my
right honorable friend the
um the Home Secretary the majority of my
constituents in City mall and Shepherd
understand that sending illegal migrants
to Rwanda for processing is key to
stopping Small Boat Crossings in the
channel so will she assure them that
despite the conservative concerted
opposition from the labor party that she
will deliver her plan
true
well I'm grateful to The Honorable
gentleman for the question we are
disappointed by the Judgment of the
court of appeal but we're determined to
follow through he's right to say that we
have to add deterrence to the system
it's only by breaking the business model
of the people Smugglers that will stop
the boats
we sing Kim McGuinness the northumbria
police and crime commissioner has put in
place a redeployment program to get an
extra 134 officers into neighborhoods
but that will not make up for the
1100 officers and the 148 million pounds
we've lost due to budget cuts and before
he mentions plans we that will still
leave us 400 officers short so why have
the Tories failed so badly to get police
officers onto the beat
[Music]
record ever police numbers 100 149
572 the previous Peak was 146 030 in
2010 so we had three and a half thousand
more officers than we have ever had
before across England and Wales in
northumbria and northumbria since uh
2015 uh the number has gone up by
512. of course many of the powers do sit
with the PCC including Powers over the
precept and it's entirely open to police
and crime Commissioners to use those
Powers
thank you Mr Speaker today op Centurion
has started across Lancashire utilizing
two million pounds from government to
put more police officers on our streets
tackling ASB in my constituency that
means an almost 2 500 extra hours of
police Patrols in padian but we can do
more it will have a Major Impact but we
can do more so could I ask the Home
Secretary whether the safer streets fund
will have another round so we can make
physical changes as well as getting more
officers on the streets
well I'm very delighted with the
progress being made to tackle
anti-social behavior in Burnley and
padaham as my honorable friend will know
we've allocated almost a million pounds
to roll out Pilots of ASB hotspot
response in 23-24 there is a new round
of safer streets being announced uh very
soon and I just want to take this
opportunity to thank Lancashire police
they've launched an ASB problem solving
unit they ran operation propulsion which
involved more officers patrolling
locations dealing with motor nuisance
and boy races and they've had a real
good Crackdown on residential burglary
thanks to operation Defender
neighborhood crime has fallen by 26 in
Lancashire uh tribute must be paid to
Chief Council Chris Rowley and the
police and crime commissioner Andrew
Snowden
but do given the exchanges earlier
obliged to ask the Home Secretary if she
understands the difference between using
a cruise ship for the temporary
accommodation of the Ukrainian refugees
with a shared language and experience
who have the right to work and who are
being actively relocated in the
community and on the other hand using it
essentially as a prison ship for the
indefinite long-term Detention of Asylum
Seekers who have no right to leave yet
no right to work no right to benefit and
no recourse to public funds does the
department appreciate the difference
I'm disappointed by The Honorable
gentleman's remarks he knows perfectly
well that the proposition was not a
prison ship this is a ship that's going
to be used in exactly the same way as
the SMP government did in Scotland and
exactly the same way as the Belgian and
the Dutch governments are doing in their
respective areas and if I may say this
Mr Speaker in Edinburgh today there are
37 Asylum Seekers that's disgrace useful
if the SMP cared about this issue they
would step up support Asylum Seekers if
they don't they'd back our bill
Mr Speaker are people in South and West
want to see a tough but just policy on
illegal immigration that stops people
unfairly jumping the queue that stops
evil people Smugglers and above all
stops vulnerable people drowning in the
channel so will my right honorable
friend agree that we must continue to
send a strong signal that it is this
government not unelected lawyers or
criminal gangs who will decide who comes
to this country
is absolutely right at the core of this
question is who decides who comes to
this country is it for the government
and Parliament or is it for people
Smugglers and human traffickers we on
this side of the house know exactly
which side of this debate we're on we
want to stop the boats we want to secure
our borders
of the family of my constituents who
fled Sudan to be stuck in Egypt for over
two months awaiting a spouse or visa for
the five of the group um have UK
passports because the minister tell us
how long he would expect people to be
waiting in this kind of situation when
they're suffered such distress and
anxiety
well I'd be happy to look into the case
for The Honorable General but I can say
to him that we are processing
applications uh in third countries
within service standards we have closed
the visa application center in Khartoum
for obvious reasons to protect the
security of our staff and contractors
but we have teams in Egypt in Saudi
Arabia and in other uh close countries
who are there to support applicants like
his constituents Theresa Village
morning's U-turn by the mayor of London
on selling off Oxbridge police station
does the minister believe that he should
also act to save Barnet police station
if he doesn't his decision on Uxbridge
looks like cynical political gameplay
Minister well I and many other londoners
were concerned when silicon I think even
2017 announced plans to close 37 police
stations thanks to the Resolute
campaigning of local councilor Steve
tuckwell in uh in in Hillingdon uh
silicon has executed a last minute
handbrake U-turn Under Pressure I'm sure
entirely unconnected with the upcoming
by-election and and my one friend is
absolutely right if silicon has had any
credibility at all with London as he
currently has pretty much none at all he
should Reserve reverse not just this one
police station closure plan but all of
his police station closure plans
thank you Mr Speaker using in the mat
using the maximum police precept on
council tax having to tap into half a
million pounds reserves and yet again
relying on grant funding shows that the
bedfordshire PCC has failed to secure
the long-term funding our Force really
desperately needs and now he's off
pursuing his personal Ambitions as an
exitory candidate in mid-beds so the
review of police funding is welcome but
can when will the house see it and will
it be before summer recess
Sinister well I can't send out a precise
time frame it is being actively worked
on but I would like to just point out
that the police and crime commissioner
uh for bedfordshire Festus is doing a
fantastic job for the people of that
County and it's thanks to his active and
energetic persuasive and eloquent
interventions that bedfordshire has
received these special grants and their
their base budget also gone up by 6.1
million pounds this year thanks to
festus's Fantastic work
I'm Mr Speaker last week Nigel farage
publicized the cancellation of his bank
accounts under the politically exposed
person's regulations but he is only the
latest of a number of people to have
their lives wrecked by this regulation
recently Lords in The Other Place have
tried to correct this policy with only
partial success I understand because of
pushback from the home office and the
security services can I also explain why
this is and what she's going to do about
it
well I'm delighted to be asked a
question today the uh
may I say yesterday the uh the treasury
and the home office came together and
agreed various things that were
announced in the Lords actually which
was the peps uh agreement so this sort
of closure on political grounds if that
is indeed what has happened and after
all we only have the allegation of it at
this point uh it should be completely
unacceptable peps is there to prevent
the corrupt use of banking facilities uh
by politicians in corrupt regimes it is
not here to silence individuals who may
hold views with which we may or may not
agree so the select committed Dame Dana
Johnson thank you Mr Speaker in the
Chief Inspector of borders and
immigrations latest report on the home
office system to remove foreign National
offenders he said the home office does
not have a firm grit on its caseworking
operations and there is no and this is
no way to run a government Department he
also said I found the home office's
inability to provide reliable or
consistent data and management
information of particular concern so
given this could the the Home Secretary
explain how the department will cope
with the increase in casework detention
and removals planned under the
immigration illegal immigration board Mr
well of course we do take that report as
all others very seriously and she's
right to say that there are lessons to
be learned I would say however that
returns are increasing that's as a
result of deals like the one we've done
with Albania it's as a result of reforms
like those we've made to the National
referral mechanism and it's also as a
result of the 50 increase in illegal
working visits that we've secured this
year alone
Mr Speaker despite repeated Assurance
system of dispatch box and nearly eight
months on from when I first raised the
issue with the minister the home office
continues to operate two wholly
inappropriate accommodation centers in
my constituency put in an unbearable
strain on public services well my
writable friend now Expedia at the time
a clear timetable to is this census
permanently and restore the hotels back
to their intended purposes
well my honorable friend and I have
discussed this on many occasions and she
has very doggedly campaigns for the
closure of these hotels as well as
supporting the steps that we're taking
as a government to stop the boats in the
first place I'd be happy to have further
conversations with her but she has my
Assurance that we are working as fast as
possible to clear all hotels including
those in her constituency
speaker last week the government
rejected a number of the recommendations
from the increases the tragic mass
shooting in Plymouth in 2021 this has
caused serious concern with some of the
families of the victims so can the
minister explain why he rejected the
coroner's recommendations and whether
all the ones he is Consulting on will be
implemented by the end of this calendar
year
for his question and for the meeting we
had with the families uh a few weeks ago
and as I said to him on the phone last
week whenever he and the families are
ready to have further discussions uh
with home office officials uh they are
ready to do that at the timing of that
will be guided by The Honorable
gentleman in terms of the substance of
the government's reply there are some
things uh We've committed to doing uh
straight away for example uh there isn't
that the npcc have been funded to set up
an accredited training program for
firearms officers that was one of the
recommendations in due course that will
become mandatory there'll be a thematic
inspection of all firearms licensing by
the inspector next year and as I said to
the house a few months ago I asked the
inspector to specifically re-inspect
Devon and cornwall's Firearms licensing
they're doing that and they should be
reporting by the end of July the vast
majority of the recommendations uh made
by the coroner and indeed by the iopc
and the Scottish Affairs Committee in
connection with the Isle of Skye
shooting are being openly and neutrally
consulted on so the government doesn't
have a position it will consult openly
and respond once we've got people's
replies to the consultation and there
were two particular recommendations he
refers to and that the government didn't
feel were appropriate for the reasons
set out in the document but the vast
majority of recommendations are being
openly consulted on and some of them
have taken action on already and I just
thank him again for his uh campaigning
on this issue which I know the families
are very grateful for
Davidson thank you Mr Speaker I recently
visited the Uxbridge police station to
hear about the valuable work its
officers do to serve my constituents as
well as those in exhibition South
ruislip when the mayor announced the
closure in 2017 Hillingdon Council
offered to buy the site at market rate
and provide a half a million pounds
Revenue contribution and Lease back
Arrangement so those valuable Services
could continue to be available but the
mayor said that was completely
impossible so other than the Relentless
campaigning Affiliated and conservatives
and councilor Steve tuckwell come over
from French yes any reason why the
mayor's decided to keep it up
Mr Simmons I think you need the German
debate not the topical question so even
better but well I thank my honorable
friend for his uh excellent question I
mean the answer is no I can't think of
anything other than the tireless
campaigning by councilor Steve tuckwell
and others that has forced the mayor
into this last minute self-interested
screeching U-turn but I'd like the mayor
to do a u-turn on all the other police
stations he's turning me closer to say
look you're going to be here a while yet
very sure Mr Speaker is the Home
Secretary concerned recent Revelations
about the investigation to the Stephen
Lawrence murder and what happened uh
during the Brinks met aftermath is she
concerned some of this social
organizations are out of work
organizations that our police belong to
and I'm secretary well the recent uh
reports relating to the Stephen Lawrence
case are
our operational matter for the police
it's something I cannot get involved in
and nor should I that is a judgment for
the police on operational and casework
decisions within which we don't
interfere but when I just say I think
that we have a good track record when it
comes to the met in terms of turning
around performance Mark rowley's
turnaround plan and his leadership
efforts to restore confidence rebuild
trust with London is working and we need
to back him to get the best results
possible in London
Nick Fletcher Mr Speaker there is a
tweet at the moment going around with
regarding a manual and identifies as a
trans woman the Tweet reads the trans
identifier manual opinion in an ITV News
report about mothers has posted an image
breastfeeding their baby do you think
it's okay to mock women like this I
think that's a valid question but I'm
also extremely concerned for the welfare
of the child the department look into
this for me please
Mr Speaker whilst we of course respect
all of the rights of uh those in the
trans Community it's obviously clear
that biological men cannot breastfeed uh
but Mr Speaker is quite remarkable that
we have gotten to a position where the
labor party leader can't actually Define
a woman I think he said something like
99.9 of women don't have a penis on that
basis we can't actually rule him out
from running to be Labor's first female
prime minister
over six months for a biometric
residence permit a period which means
she can't work access free healthcare or
leave the country we somebody do
something and get her early status she
deserves what she want her life
Minister I'll be happy to look into the
case for the Army gentleman
the number of foreign National offenders
eligible for deportation has now reached
a record of almost 12 000 almost 4 000
of these left prison more than five
years ago and even those who are
volunteering for deportation are still
here will a minister get a grip on the
deportation Department within the home
office and make sure that these people
are chucked out of our country
Minister well The Honorable gem is
absolutely right we want these
individuals to leave the country as
swiftly as possible the published
figures show that ethano returns have
increased following the pandemic in the
latest 12-month period ending December
22 by 14 compared to the previous
12-month period but quite clearly
there's more work to be done Johnson
thank you Mr Speaker Liverpool's
pools 237 Afghan families in a half down
Hotel languishing there for two years
the council have to re-house these
families by the 11th of August can the
minister say what will happen if we're
unable to find suitable accommodation
will they be made homeless and thrown
out on the street
well the minister for Veterans Affairs
and I have launched a program that
provides significant support to councils
like Liverpool to help individuals to
find alternative accommodation that
might be in the private rental sector it
might be in social housing but I think
we can all agree on the principle that
it is not right for individuals or
families to live in hotel accommodation
for over two years we need to help those
people out of the hotels this summer
Chris Stephen cute Mr Speaker it'll come
his news to the immigration Minister's
claim earlier to the labor and
conservative Coalition who run north
lanarkshire Council and I also are
surprised to a director of Mayors who
confirms to me that North Arlington
Council house not just a sign Seekers
but refugees when is the immigration
Minister now three times has given
factually wrong information to this
house when we apologize to this house
and will we come back to it to give
proper information
well I don't think I have given
factually wrong information it may not
be the fact that the honorable gentleman
wants to hear but they are the facts I
didn't mention North lanarkshire but now
he does uh there are six Asylum seekers
in North lanarkshire there's more to be
done here I think the envelopment would
agree
that completes questions